[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
tuesday august 23rd i'm zoe thomas for
the wall street journal
back in 2014 a week after apple launched
its new contactless payment system apple
pay
ceo tim cook spoke at the wall street
journal's big annual tech conference
where he was asked about reports that
some big name u.s retailers were
refusing to accept apple pay
cook characterized the standoff with the
retailers as a skirmish and struck a
positive tone about apple pay's future
now we've got a lot more to go we've got
a lot of merchants to sign up
we've got a lot more banks to sign up
and we have the whole rest of the world
we're only in the us right now
and so we're just getting started
uh but
the
early
ramp looks fantastic and i'm getting
that sunny outlook well it seems like
it's finally come to pass and it seems
like everyone is using apple pay
it just took eight years
with the speed the tech typically moves
that duration and the steadfast belief
that a product will live up to its goals
despite initially slow adoption
is rare
joining us to discuss what apple's
endurance can teach the tech world is
ben cohen the wsj's science of success
columnist hi ben thanks for joining me
hi thanks for having me so plot this
course for us that apple took from you
know it's launch to now how did it
increase usership of apple pay when it
looked like in the beginning this wasn't
really going to happen for it
yeah in the beginning apple pay was sort
of widely dismissed and almost mocked i
mean no one really thought that it would
be a success and
for a very long time it wasn't so apple
pay was introduced in 2014 by 2016 only
10
of iphones had activated apple pay by
2017 that number was only 20 and so
three years into the service by which
time tim cook had already declared 2015
to be the year of apple pay and in 2016
said that it was happening much faster
than he anticipated it really did not
look like it was going to be a consumer
hit and yet
the adoption rate doubled the next year
and then it hit 50 by the start of the
pandemic and now the activation rate for
apple pay on iphones is around 75
percent yeah it's interesting because
tim cook and apple seem to have so much
faith that apple pay was gonna pay off
for it but how did it get that kind of
adoption when it looked like it was
moving so slowly how did they get to a
75 activation rate so there were a few
things the first is that they were very
very annoying and
sometimes pestering can help so there
was a while when if you hadn't activated
apple pay you would see this little red
bubble on your iphone that you wanted to
you know get rid of and so people
started adding their credit cards and
debit cards to the apple wallet just so
they would have a cleaner iphone to look
at but that was one thing but the real
thing was that they needed the rest of
the world and especially the united
states to catch up to their vision of
the future so when apple pay was
introduced only about three percent of
retailers and stores in the united
states had the technological
infrastructure for contactless payments
so if you tried to use apple pay you
wouldn't have been able to in the
beginning that number is now 90
apple says so some of it was waiting for
stores to get there and the rest of it
was humans and human behavior had to
change so when apple looked at the rest
of the world and the way that europe
especially used contactless payments
they saw that they were several years
ahead of the united states and that gave
them confidence that americans weren't
so different from the rest of the world
it would just take a little bit of time
to catch up and then the last thing that
that happened that really accelerated
the growth of apple pay and changed its
trajectory was the pandemic and you know
there was a time when people did not
want to hand their cards over to
cashiers or stick their credit cards
into terminals and just being able to
hold your phone near a reader was a much
more preferable option how did they get
the stores on board how did they start
getting more places to accept apple pay
in part because more people wanted to
use apple pay right you know some of it
was just time for stores to upgrade
their own technological infrastructures
and add contactless terminals so this
was never going to happen overnight and
i think apple knew that and you know
sometimes it can be hard for companies
to stay patient but you know the long
game is an indulgence that the world's
richest corporation could afford right
like if there were anyone that could
afford to be patient it was apple and i
think this is sort of a case study and
how valuable that patient can be in
business sometimes
yeah let's let's talk about that a
little bit i mean why did apple even
stick with this to get apple pay kind of
to this level in the first place
for one thing you know they had data
from other parts of the world that
suggested it was going to work even if
it wasn't quite working in the united
states already but the second thing is
that this is not just about how we spend
money in restaurants or at stores right
i mean apple is really trying to
make the physical wallet obsolete they
want your phone to replace the wallet
and that means
putting credit cards on your phone it
means putting your driver's license and
id and insurance cards on your phone i
mean there is research that human beings
would rather leave home without their
wallets than without their phones and if
apple can come up with a service like
this that makes the iphone more useful
and more valuable that is just you know
incredibly beneficial to their bottom
line
is this something though that another
company could have pulled off i mean you
called it an indulgence tech is known
for kind of that move fast and break
things culture so could other companies
afford to wait around for a new
technology or for consumer habits to
change probably not right and not just
wait around for consumer habits to
change but make those consumer habits
change like have the market power and
the sheer force of will to kind of bend
human behavior to their favor but i
think it's worth keeping patients in
mind because i think that moving fast
and breaking things has become like for
a while it was so popular among tech
companies and and that kind of ethos
trickle down to all
sectors of society and i think that you
know patience is kind of undervalued all
right that's wsj science of success
columnist ben cohen ben thanks so much
for joining us thank you for having me
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing if you're looking for more tech
stories check out our website wsj.com
and if you enjoy the show please leave
us a five star rating and a review
wherever you get your podcasts it really
does help
i'm zoe thomas for the wall street
journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]